[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip nous avons
aujourd'hui l'invité yvelinoise qui sort
un second livre raphaël bernard bach au
bonjour bonjour merci d'être présente
sur le plateau de tv 78 vous êtes ici en
tant qu' un peu versaillaise au sylvie
noise et versailles est ce parce que
vous collaborez au célèbre mensuel
versailles plus c'est vrai ça absolument
ouais j'ai chef que vous y faites alors
j'ai écrit une chronique il faut se dire
que tout commence par le dessin c'est
vraiment mon métier
donc je dessine j'ai dessiné beaucoup
aux protégés du froid j'ai fait un
carnet de bord qui a d'ailleurs été
utilisée pour mon premier livre vous
savez ce qu'on est en train de faire là
enfin elle est on en train de faire tout
à l'envers juste je voulais dire votre
chronique c'est sur le dessin et sur la
botanique dans versailles plus donc ça
c'est dit on y reviendra après et votre
formation
racontez moi c'est ça ce que je voulais
préciser c'est que c'est une cro dit
écrite et décider c'est ça d'un peu
l'originalité visuelle où il parle de
ses logos c'est mon grand défaut alors
du coup votre formation à ma formation
j'ai fait l'école supérieure d'arts
graphiques qui est une école comme le
nom indique et
kipré enfin qui prépare à tous les
métiers visuel d'accord qui te d'école
qui qui tient la route c'est une école
qui gagnent beaucoup de foin de grande
réputation parmi tous les les recruteurs
de directeur artistique illustrateurs et
maintenant évidemment tous les sites
internet
donc en fait on y apprend le dessin et
c'est vrai que c'est assez fréquent
oui seigneur avant le dessin là il est
bizarre c'est qu'en plus du tout à
l'ordre du jour est donc et moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié ça parce que je trouve
que c'est par le dessin qu'on regarde le
monde en fait
oui c'est ce que vous dites vous dites
par le dessin c'est comme ça qu'on
voyait le mieux exactement ça veut dire
quoi
elle c'est à dire qu'on s'a apprend à
observer série c c'est juste quelques
minutes supplémentaires on n'a pas quand
on prend des photos faites quand on
prend des photos on découvre dans la
faute au tir et eau sur écran oui alors
voilà ça va plus vite et en même temps
donc on n'a pas le temps de remarquer en
fait tous les détails qui font le sel de
la vie
je comprends alors justement ce fameux
détails qui font le sel de la vie vous
les avez croqué dans un premier ouvrage
qui s'appelle potager du roi numide
alors que vous avez crié combien de
temps alors gelé en fait le livre est
sorti à trois ans et j'ai donc écrit un
en fait ça s'est passé assez rapidement
puisque j'avais déjà fait mon carnet de
bord était l'âme la base du livre
et quand j'ai eu donc la commande des
éditions glénat belge et voilà je me
suis lancé je suis devenu auteur et
je me suis évidemment beaucoup documenté
puisque c'était un aspect historique
aussi évoqué botanique donc vous y
alliez sur place
voilà donc en fait j'allais sur place
depuis longtemps qu'elles aient toutes
les semaines c'était un peu le rythme et
sur place improvisé suivant les saisons
suivant les jardiniers qui étaient
visibles suivant les récoltes du jour
voilà c'est parce que c'est rigolo c'est
que vous vous avez commencé par dessiner
des danseurs donc les gens en mouvement
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant et après
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous
êtes passé des danseurs aux fruits dont
ccvd j'exécute sage explique ça
justement dans le livre du potager du
roi j'appelle ça ma petite histoire et
je fais un petit clin d'oeil en disant
que j'étais comme louis xiv qui
s'intéressait à la danse et au potager
et donc voilà donc la danse
contemporaine c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours fasciné contemporaine parce
que la danse classique je trouve que
c'est plus ennuyeux dessinée et ccc des
canaux et postures voilà exactement donc
la danse contemporaine c'est quand on a
commencé comme en affaires du modèle
vivant parce que c'est la base quand
même du dessin on est irrémédiablement
attirés par les danseurs parce qu'ils
ont une maîtrise du mouvement qui est
magnifique
voilà donc je suis venu petit à petit
j'ai dessiné dès son cousin en fait
c'est à dire que quand on apprend on
apprend avec des pauses de une minute
deux minutes 3000 mais souvent un quart
d'heure et que je trouvais très
ennuyeuse et donc petit à petit j'ai
aimé faire signe à des danseurs et puis
un jour les danses me suis dit mais
pourquoi pas faire la verse plutôt que
danseurs viennent dans l'atelier
allez moi la rencontre et la lie dans
les studios de danse et voilà et donc je
sais ce que j'ai fait c'était
passionnant j'ai vraiment fait des très
belles rencontres vraiment j'ai dessiné
avec des grands chorégraphes qui auront
été vraiment accueillants voilà comme
caroline carson qu'a montré le chemin
c'était fabuleux
et ce qui m'intéressait c'est de
dessiner pendant leur pièce mais au
moment de l'élaboration oui oui bon on
cherchait il ya d'autres artistes ont
fait ça yakitri turbine notamment une
assise steve des noës qui est citée aux
répétitions du béjart ballet lausanne
calais schille un seul même esprit ouais
voilà après on est passé aux fruits dont
c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors en fait les fûts dans ces mondes
donc je bougeais bouger beaucoup quand
j'ai décidé des danseurs et amant donné
je me suis dit pour sa vie donc j'ai la
chance d'habiter avec un jardin donc et
c'est vrai que devant mon atelier il y
avait un cognassier et un jour revenant
comme ça de mes périples parce que je
suis allé assez loin parfois j'avais des
commandes de deux festivals de danse
j'ai buté sur un coin je me suis dit
j'ai eu je me suis dit mais pourquoi pas
dessiner des fruits qui m'ont toujours
plus parce que je suis j'ai toujours été
proche de la nature et je garde un
souvenir merveilleux du potager mon
grand-père kto qui était en seine et
marne
et voilà donc je me suis dit mais je
vais commencer à dessiner et j'aime
beaucoup le pastel donc j'essaie de
faire des recherches sur des papiers
recyclés et voilà de fil en aiguille
j'ai commencé à dessiner des
des fruits et des légumes et évidemment
je me suis intéressé j'ai recherché un
potager où il ya une grande variété
d'accord donc le ballottage et du roi
l'autre côté du roi mais ce qui était
pas simple c'est qu'il fallait quand
même demandé à laisser passer à parler
vous l'avez eue je n'ai eu voilà d'où ce
joli livre à quillan voilà voilà
aujourd'hui vous sortez jamie et des
villes portraits croqués sur le vif
peut-être qu'on va voir là la couverture
voiliers et quand vous parliez de danse
tout est en mouvement finalement dans
vos jardins
il ya plusieurs alors vous avez croqué
différents portraits de jardiniers alors
là vous avez mis un peu sur le même
piédestal si je puis dire la botanique
et l'humain puisque vous traitez les
deux chaque convoi sur chaque planche un
jardin et un jardinet et il ya un petit
texte qui explique ce que vous avez un
peu attrapé de ce que vous êtes touchés
chez la personne j'imagine mais tout ce
que c'est court mais tout de suite on
est touché voilà donc là qu'est ce qu'on
voit à l'écran on parle de sylvia ou est
ce qu'elle se trouve sylvie son jardin
le jardin de sylvie
en fait c'est une parcelle qui fait
partie des potagers familiaux de
saint-cloud d'accord donc le principe
c'est que donc on loue à l'année par
celle qui ces principes des jardins
ouvriers alors exactement mais c'est
qu'ils sont dans la ville alors ici oui
en fait ils sont ceux là sont dans le
parc de saint cloud dans la ville de
saint cloud donc ils sont assez
privilégié parce qu' un entourage de
parcs mai mais ils sont chacun leur
petit lot alors je crois que c'était 200
via la même chose le mètre carré n'est
jamais envoyé qu'on le web voilà en fait
c'est quelque chose c'est le principe
qui a été très en vogue au début du
siècle c'était l'abbé lemire qui avait
institué ça et à l'époque c'était pour
détourner les hommes des cabarets à
planter leurs légumes
voilà exactement quelle équipe très
puissante annales et ouais et évidemment
au moment des deux comment les deux
guerres ça a été précieux parce que
c'était vraiment logique inverse
simplement ici c'est encore le cas pour
beaucoup de personnes me est tout à fait
et tout à fait il y en a qui sont très
producteurs afin qu'ils produisent
énormément de deux de légumes vins qui
font ça de façon alors ce sont des
amateurs mais je trouve que certains
font ça presque mieux que les
professionnels voilà et c'est ce qui m'a
intéressé c'est après les jardiniers
professionnels du potager du roi s'est
passé justement aux amateurs ou alors
des professionnels y est libre
finalement voix libres de faire ce
qu'ils on vit à leur façon parce que ce
que vous dites aussi très joliment c'est
qu'à chaque jardin correspond une façon
de jardiner puisque le jardinier est
unique et l'huile à ses convictions ses
façons de faire il a ses propres plantes
ou parler d'un jardinier marco qui est
italien qui quand il ya le mal du pays
bien content de retrouver les skis l'a
rapporté 2 d'italie qui l'a planté dans
son jardin
chacun a un peu sa marotte sa spécialité
absolument
voilà autant de jardiniers voilà c'est
exactement et il y en a un qui est
incroyable qui fait des greffes
alors oui ça non extraordinaire mais
c'est toi la goutte d'or donc à paris
dans le quartier de la goutte d'or
il ya donc ça c'est s'aider des parcs et
des jardins partagés donc c'est un petit
peu différent comme mon concept et lui
se
il s'appelait déjà lui c'était je sais
plus c'est pas grave et égyptien
d'origine égyptienne wii est en fait il
de passionnés de plantes et il
hébergeait toutes les plantes des
migrants brosse un quartier il ya
beaucoup d'allées et venues des gens de
passage et il prenait soin des plantes
mais c'est la part des migrants qui
parfois revenait parfois ne revenais pas
ouais là et il est passionné jeu bref
oui alors qu'elle sait pas où est ce
qu'ils avaient appris ça mais il essaie
des trucs c'était vraiment presque
inquiétant par jakub jardin le vôtre de
l'association ils accueillent à
versailles donc on lui a laissé une
parcelle de jardin ce média coupe c'est
une histoire très touchante il trouvait
que l'intérim en trois mots où il ya
coupe
yacoub été un peu la mascotte de
versailles même du potager du roi en
fait il était donc hébergé par
versailles accueille et versailles
accueille s'est entendu avec
l'association le colibri pour partager
un jardin pas jardins partagés mandat
d'enquêter sur deux niveaux le niveau
le colibri d'une part et les migrants de
l'autre et il était complètement fasciné
enfin c'est à dire qu'il a il a pris
très rapidement
il sait apprivoiser il a apprivoisé le
lieu l'heure c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de bénévoles qui ont montrent
qu'ils ont mis en place des choses qui
ont été chercher des accessoires we love
à rien d'agir et au début il n'y avait
pas d'eau il n'y a pas d'eau courante
donc il a fallu aller chercher après la
q1 et voilà et c'était extraordinaire
parce qu'il avait un vrai sens de la
plante vraiment les mains vertes
c'était où il a les mains vertes et au
large avait les mains vertes jardiner je
ne suis pas sûr en tout cas j'aime ça
j'aime voir les j'aime voir les plans
pousser et vous avez la mission que ces
jardins en ville sont vitaux finalement
pour les pour les attentes ça correspond
vraiment à une envie profonde des
citadins d'aujourd'hui en est
aujourd'hui
on a vraiment besoin on a besoin de cet
oxygène on a besoin de cette de pouvoir
s'évader même dans un tout petit espace
peu importe
et puis c'est un tel plaisir de voir la
plante sortir la graine germée même ceux
mais voila voila je pense qu'il ya aussi
une dimension de sérénité de qui est
tellement important surtout en ce moment
et d'ailleurs je les ai entendus dire à
l'alitement oui c'est ça un rapport là
je sais que les jardiniers
c'était très dur parce que par exemple
les jardins familiaux de versailles ont
été fermés pendant tout le confinement
et pendant déconfinement ça s'est fait
vraiment progressivement et c'est que
depuis une semaine ou deux que qu'ils
ont de nouveau accès et je pense que
ça a été très dur à la fois
psychologiquement et ensuite de trouver
son potager évidemment qu'ils avaient
besoin dit n'a pas il déçoit mais ou qui
avaient soif ou alors c'est et rap
voilà écoutez on n'a pas parlé de la
femme de nature et découvertes et de
l'altesse j'irai me line à win qui est
là mais le temps qui nous est imparti
est maintenant terminée mais c'est pas
grave moi j'encourage tout le monde à
lier ce magnifique lille il ya autant
pour les yeux que pour l'esprit enfin
les textes sont vraiment sympathiques
qu'ils ont ça peut plaire à beaucoup de
gens jardiner ou pas absolument voilà
c'est pas livre purement botanique
normalement elle livre soit des
histoires humaines exact wall a croqué
sur le vif comme vous dites si bien
alors raphaël dernière bako merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui vous remercie
j'avais des signatures de prévus ou
alors bon c'était un peu limité mais
j'ai trouvé de livres et ricky qui ont
des terrasses un génial à la alors il ya
la librairie botanique à paris qui se
trouve sur une péniche
ouais et lowe's 9e 1 9 quai de l'oise et
l'autre à ville d'avray dans mon village
et c'est une prairie qui s'appelle mille
feuilles qui a la chance d'avoir une
grande terrasse qui domine un jardin bon
alors le public pourra éventuellement
vous c'est donc le 24 juin à ville
d'avray et le 20 juin samedi 20 juin
après midi à la peine à paris voilà
d'accord peut-être un jour dans les
yvelines on sait jamais abba avec
plaisir oui je vous êtes au super voilà
merci beaucoup
raphaël est encore vrai merci
[Musique]